Shadow Minister for Health and Social
care laborers Liz Kendall joins me in
the studio lovely to see you this
morning nice to see you too
um I I wonder if I might just get a
little word from you on that situation
in solihull I mean I I cannot begin to
imagine what the parents of those poor
children are are going through but we
just need to remind our kids don't we
you know the ice might look thick the
ice might look safe but it may well not
be I think it is um every parent's
absolute worst nightmare
um I've just had a boy myself and first
thing I thought when I
saw this this morning was imagining how
I would feel and how important it is to
be careful and to warn children but
right now I just my heart goes out to
them and it has and to all their family
and friends you must be devastated too
they will be and congratulations to you
as well
um let's let's talk about the strikes
however and of course what we are seeing
today Unison members in Northern Ireland
will be going on strike in addition
we've also had that that official
request from the government to to bring
in the military to drive ambulances it's
all looking pretty Grim this winter when
it comes to the state of the Health
Service isn't it I mean it really is we
know already we've got seven million
patients on the waiting list four
hundred thousand waiting more than a
year it's not acceptable so that's why I
think that Steve Barkley the health
secretary should accept the offer from
the rcnn Unison this 11th Hour offer we
will pause the strikes they said if you
meet with us to discuss pay or if you
don't want to meet with us directly go
through the arbitration service acass I
personally think it's unforgivable that
he isn't meeting with them because
they've said we will pause the strikes
if you meet with us he needs to do that
and he needs to do that today if labor
were in government at the moment what
would they be offering nurses well we
have always wanted to see our nurses get
Fair pay when we were in government we
made sure that that's what happened but
I'm not going to promise you or your
viewers today pluck a figure out of
nowhere because God only knows what the
state if the economy is going to be in
two years time and we have only made
promises when we've showed how we'll pay
for them I think nurses deserve that but
we would absolutely meet discuss and
negotiate with them and we would always
show how we would pay for that sure but
but don't nurses also deserve to know
the general public does have to know
that whether or not labor would be
offering more money than is on the table
from the government of course we want to
see nurses have a fair pay rise
but I believe if you make a promise you
should be able to stick to it and that's
why we can't as I said pluck a figure
out of nowhere but let's just take a
step and criticize the government for
the way in which they are behaving
because they're not even meeting the
nurses that's what I'm criticizing them
for you know when we were in government
we regularly met uh doctors nurses to
discuss all of these issues I can't
believe they aren't just doing that but
let me just take a step back about why
we are in this situation in the first
place it is not just that the government
crashed the economy with their mini
budget their disastrous minutes but it's
that for 12 long years we've had no or
pathetically weak economic growth so we
haven't had the money to put into our
public services including for a fair pay
worth that is the reason we're in this
mess not simply because of the current
situation but because of this long
record that's what the government needs
to change okay but when it comes when it
comes to pain I'm sorry to keep laboring
this point when labor says it we
negotiate with with nursing unions you
seem to be implying that you had been in
essence be ripping up the independent
peer review body recommendations is that
correct no we we always use the
recommendations of the independent pay
review but negotiations have always
happened between employers and employees
you have to have those discussions
that's what the government has failed to
take action on I don't want to see those
strikes happening in the NHS if you you
know I used to run the ambulance service
network that represents all ambulance
trusts I know that paramedics those are
999 calls they don't go into this for
the money they go into it for a vocation
but my Hospital in Leicester has got a
food bank for nurses that's unacceptable
we need proper funding for our Public
Services by growing the economy and we
need a government that will actually sit
down and start those discussions why
that is the shadow Health secretary
picking a fight with the doctors unions
the nurses unions and so on and so forth
I mean a remarkable interview that he
gave to the Sunday Telegraph yesterday
you know this is labor the party of
Labor you know being openly critical
about these organizations saying that
they are vested interests and so on and
so forth I mean politically what on
Earth is he up to now actually if you
read the headline I don't if you read
the actual story not the headline it's
very different look Wes is absolutely
right to say we need more GPS that's why
Labor's plan will double the number of
medical school places uh funded by
getting rid of the non-dom tax status
but in return for that we also need to
see changes I don't want people waiting
for hours on the phone to get a GP
appointment people should be able to
have the right to see their doctor face
to face if they want that that's what
wiz was saying that is not the unions
had to be fair well that's what he said
I think it is not unreasonable for
people to be able to get to see their GP
and to be able to see them face to face
I'm sure that that's what your viewers
will think too so GPS are under
phenomenal pressure the that's why we
have spelled out how we will double the
number of medical school places
including for people who want to be GPS
but in return we've got to be able to
get you know my parents have struggled
uh they they live in Sussex ringing
ringing to try and see the GP and the GP
says unless it's an absolute emergency
we can't see that that's not right
that's not right but we need to change
the way things work just a word then on
on you know people working in the Health
Professions at the moment now you saw
what it was like on your way into the
studio this morning the Pavements will
ice up people will be falling in huge
numbers there will be people who require
care not necessarily urgent not
necessarily life in limb care but they
will require care that will not be able
to get it on these straight days because
of the stroke do you think that that
should serve not to focus the minds of
those in government but Focus minds of
those who are working on the front line
they really are focused you know if you
speak to anybody who's been working in
the NHS particular particularly during
covid they have given their all they've
risked their own lives by doing that
they are absolutely pushed to Breaking
Point here as I said having to my
hospital having to have a food bank
that's not right you know there are
already huge staff shortages and the
thing is this can be solved it can be
solved but the government needs to get
round the table and sort it out
congratulations again on the we won Buzz
Kendall thanks for being with us